hey guys you know that I love fishing
right with Rod and Reel but also fishing
men and women for Christ that's why our
new merch is out it's ready to be
ordered fisher of men Matthew 4. this is
a reminder for you to not just go and
enjoy life you know your normal Hobbies
like fishing
but to go and fish for men and women to
accept Jesus Christ as Lord and a savior
while they still have time so I love
fishing and I'm here actually now and I
might go in and see if I can catch
anything here as well so we can enjoy
life but also remember to look at the
people around you and share the gospel
with them this is a great gift that you
can buy for a friend a father even for
you woman out there if you love fishing
but also for the men in your life they
love fishing then you're going to get
them this t-shirt here as a gift as a
reminder that they are a child of God
and they need to be fisher of men love
you guys speak to you soon bye